final question and then we'll hope
because this congressman is this
chairman said America you know this is
the battle between good and evil and and
America is always on the side of the
good is America always on the side of
the good no we wish we were any time you
you know values are a critically
important part of American foreign
policy but also so is realism sometimes
we look at our history there's times
when we've really erred on the side of
this fellow is on our side may not be to
our liking I think there's the famous
quote in America American history who
may be a bastard but he's our bastard
you know our son of a and so no
but but more and more you know there's
you asked a question about the use of
force while it's appropriate you know
there's just war theory and
international law and we try to follow
that as much as possible connect the two
conversations before the and after the
movie because the argument before the
movie was to try to recrystallize Europe
with the help of crusade and kind of a
wimpy Christianity that was associated
with pacifism was was what kind of put
down what I wanted to ask then is what
does one make of say the claim of the
Apostle Paul which has very very famous
saying do not be overcome by evil but
overcome evil with good right so so kind
of there's a fundamental framing of
resistance within the moral frame of not
just pursuing good but acting in a good
way right
whether crusade is compatible with that
would be my question to you but to Mike
as well this history was narrated
starting with whether the drive of
Russians over the Soviets from from
Afghanistan from your perspective would
that have been the case of trying
to overcome evil with good in helping
the Afghans defend themselves in in this
entire story that was that was there is
this the case is this how one overcomes
in your judgment evil with good or to go
do accept this as a principle that
actually evil cannot be overcome by
simple force but the evil has to be
overcome with the good the only way evil
doesn't thrive is if it is overcome by
good no so I I think it's both but I
mean if I if I understand what you're
saying would we have been better off if
we didn't fight the Second World War I
think not I think the world is a better
place because Hitler and Nazi Germany
are gone and the Japanese Empire is gone
I think it the world is a better place
because we won the Cold War in the West
I think the same thing about the war
with the global jihadists and al Qaeda
that you know they killed a lot of
Americans I don't have any qualms about
capturing them or or or killing some of
them I think again you have to use just
war theory and you know that you have to
have a right cause you have to have
proper authority you have to have a
reasonable chance of success you have to
use proportionate means
but one of the core principles in
international law is the right of
self-defense so the Soviets invaded
other country does that country not have
a right to defend itself conversation at
the year is the first table when you
asked why is good weak and if one
considers the question and in the
framework of international relations I
think one of the answers has to be is
that too many good people confuse
goodness with innocence and goodness
implies agency if you're going to act
against evil then the word act implies
that you possess the capabilities that
are necessary to act efficaciously
against evil which means and this is
what I'm getting at
in order for good to be effective in
world people who believe in good and we
can define that in a thousand ways have
to overcome a certain allergy to power
that they sometimes have I mean one of
the reasons in my view that the world
right now is the most Hobbesian place
that we have seen since before World War
one and why there is so much so many
atrocities and cruelty in the world
committed by governments against their
own citizens and against citizens in
other countries is because the United
States has quit the world we are gone
Obama started pulling us out Trump
finished it and basically it is
springtime for dictators right now an
action will always bring trouble back
when that's right when you have a lot of
I do believe I truly believe even though
I'm a guy who saw a lot of evil people
and evil deeds with my own eyes and I
survived through it I truly truly
believe that the mass majority of people
are good and kind and that we can all
live together and we can all help each
other but when this huge amounts of huge
crowds of good people see bad people
saying bad ideas radical ideas trying to
attack the truth as a concept as as
itself to try to do all this harmful
things and keep just asking them nicely
or trying to somehow convince them that
this is wrong and you should stop do it
and they keep on doing it and we don't
do anything about it that's how we lost
in action will eventually bring weakness
and eventually will bring disaster Syria
was an example we got sold out for the
Iran deal a President Obama sold Syria
as a part of the Iran deal to get his
legacy passed I spent a lot of time in
DC I went to congressmen I went to
Senators to the White House to the DoD
to United Nations to the Security
Council I've been all over the place and
unfortunately unlike your movie I didn't
meet a nice Congress
who will just take this on his shoulder
and pass it on there was a lot of good
people inside the US government who
truly believed that action is necessary
in Syria but unfortunately Obama sold us
out because of his legacy what does it
take for us to become more humane or
more simple what does it take to finally
have some peace in the Middle East I
have some experts around the table who
can tell us when we will have some peace
in the Middle East Mike what will be
your strategy so make you president yeah
we get true power to your beautiful are
number one is Lama is a great religion
and great culture we we in the West are
not at war with Islam we are war with
the small group of global jihadists
there are 1.5 billion Muslims in the
world there about 200,000 global
jihadists if you count generously the
strategy then has to be to deal with
those 200,000 not try to alienate the
1.5 billion that's precisely what the
global jihadist want us to do they want
a clash of civilizations between Islam
and the West are basically the Islam and
everybody else we would be stupid to do
that the Islamic states are vests are
our best partners honestly in this
because ultimately it's an intra
civilizational conflict that you know we
have to help them restore stability to
their areas but civilizational clash
would be a disaster if you thought the
Crusades turned out badly try this one
on for size
you